[Music]
on this monday night new alarm in
ontario
schools shut down and hospitals struggle
to free up space
we really have no bad dire days ahead as
canada now fares worse than the u.s
in daily case counts alberta's premier
defends his pandemic protocols
abstract political principles don't stop
people from piling up in intensive care
units
as covid fatigue and frustration rises
across the country
another black man in the u.s killed at
the hands of police
the officer says it was an accident and
observing ramadan in a pandemic islam
is a very social religion how muslims in
canada
are adapting tradition
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
evidence is mounting what a dire
situation some provinces have reached
with covid19
today ontario announced schools across
the province will move to remote
learning for an indefinite period
try to limit the spread of the variants
they're still winning the race with the
vaccines
and canada's trajectory right now is
worse than our neighbor to the south
back in january daily cases peaked in
both the u.s and canada
since then they've been dropping in the
u.s and rising
in canada which is now outpacing the u.s
on a per capita basis
yesterday canada reported more than 223
new cases per 1 million people
the us 211. six of canada's provinces
are
leading the way alberta has the most
active cases per capita now at 323
ontario isn't far behind with 223
and more than 4 400 new cases were
reported in ontario today adding to the
already enormous strain
on hospitals record numbers of covid
patients need intensive care
hospitals in the greater toronto area
have been told to close their pediatric
units
to free up space and staff elective and
non-urgent surgeries are being postponed
and that may not be enough the situation
in ontario hospitals has never been
more dire mike durley has our top story
tonight
for months ontarians have been warned a
third wave of covet 19 could be the
worst one yet
and there's no denying the rise in icu
cases over
two-thirds of the over 600 patients in
hospital are on ventilators
leading to the difficult decision to
cancel all elective surgeries
it's the right decision right now in our
hospitals we really have no beds
that means only emergency surgeries for
things like heart attacks or trauma will
continue
joint replacements cataracts even cancer
surgeries have been put off
until the covid cases decrease leaving
patients with chronic pain at home
waiting beth perfect who suffers from
debilitating back pain
had been bumped to the top of the list
for spinal surgery
just over a year ago i started to get
radiating leg pain that's extremely
intense
and that radiating leg pain has become
unbearable
she got the call last friday her surgery
was on
two days later another call it had been
canceled
it's overwhelming how emotional it is it
really is a rollercoaster of emotions
because there isn't any relief from the
pain but the thought that a surgery can
make that pain go away
and then to have that sort of snatch
from you
you know ontario has yet to make up for
the surgeries cancelled during the first
wave
and the backlog of over 250 000
surgeries could take
years to clear up it's going to be a
very long road
and trying to just as uh as quickly as
we're revving down we also have to
appreciate how much work and effort
it's going to be to rem services back up
and
try to catch up with all those canceled
surgeries many of the doctors and nurses
who perform those surgeries are
currently working in icus with covet
patients
the system say healthcare workers is
straining to keep
up i mean this need if the alarms have
not been sounded
like by this point maybe this will sound
the best for people to really understand
what's going on because they can tell
you it's getting frustrated
when people are complaining about
schools being closed and businesses
being closed
and and restaurants being closed like i
think people really don't understand
this situation that we're facing given
the rise in new
cases not enough people do mike drew
like global news toronto
late today the ontario government
announced it is reversing course and
switching schools right across the
province to online learning
after the april break premier ford was
asked why for weeks
he resisted calls to put tighter
restrictions in place to stop the spread
this is part of his answer it's easy
and i'm not saying you rob but it's easy
for people to sit back
and say should have could have would
have done this done that
walk a mile in someone's shoes it's
never the premier or doug ford sitting
in some corner making a decision
there's hundreds and hundreds of people
uh that are part of
every single decision that we make down
here
alberta has the highest rate of active
covet 19 cases in the country right now
still premier jason kenny is defending
what he says are some of the least
stringent covid 19 restrictions
in much of the western world he is
facing pressure from within his own
party to loosen protocols even further i
would say
we have tried to take a uh balanced
approach because of our alberta belief
in freedom and personal responsibility
but
uh you know abstract political
principles
don't stop people from piling up in
intensive care units
and threatening the limited capacity of
our health care system
alberta's latest modeling projects there
could be 2 000 new cases a day by the
end of this
month that could result in five to six
hundred people
in hospital there has been frustration
and anger in alberta with the
restrictions but
nothing like the vandalism in montreal
last night hundreds turned out to
protest the curfew and some
escalated things starting fires and
breaking windows of businesses that
are already struggling mike armstrong
reports on the mounting frustration
this is the aftermath up and down the
streets of old montreal monday morning
crews were outside repairing broken
glass
while inside staff was trying to clean
broken glass
off of everything this was just pure
acts of violence and it's my
neighborhood so i'm really concerned
about it
now it started as a protest the montreal
region's coven 19 curfew
was moved earlier sunday night from 9 30
pm to 8.
the crowd stayed out there are people on
big microphones
screaming la libelte by the time it was
over police handed out more than 100
tickets for violating curfew and
arrested seven it is not acceptable
don't attack people that are already
suffering
there have been protests since the
beginning of the pandemic but after
close to 14 months
frustration may be growing this was
kentville ontario last week
a group gathering at a restaurant that
was supposed to be closed
canadians are free those
same frustrations were out in force
outside edmonton sunday
alberta health services had ordered the
grace life church closed
and fenced off after it flooded the
rules for months
protesters at one point tried to pull
the fence down
the government is trying to destroy the
family and the church
health officials across the country are
having to battle frustration on one hand
and
misinformation on the other the goal is
to get people to follow the rules to
hang on for a couple more months when
vaccinations will have an impact
the problem is getting that message
across we just need to
make them understand this bug is not the
same bug as last year
this thing is very infectious it attacks
everybody
the biggest challenge may be the finish
line it's already moved
over and over and covid19 fatigue is to
be expected
it's also something that could cost
lives
mike armstrong global news montreal
cases of covit have spread so fast in
canada's most popular ski resort
whistler that the province closed it
down
now the focus is on vaccinating everyone
over the age of eighteen
robin gail explains the rollout and what
it's hoped it will lead to
whistler has always been a favorite
destination for tourists
it now has an unfortunate reputation as
one of the country's coveted 19 hot
spots
that's why british columbia's
immunization campaign is focusing on
this resort community
of 13 000 people and the relief is
palpable
we're pretty high risk town so i think
it's about time that
we've got it this part of canada has
been a vector for the variance of
concern
for months the more contagious mutations
of kova 19 hitched a ride with travelers
from other parts of the country
they then spread to british columbians
who were also vacationing in whistler
we feel that we're at a place now where
we've got to get better containment
of this surge between january and april
the community recorded more than 1500
cases
fueled by these variants modeling
experts predicted this
spike and warned the province to
expedite the shots for essential workers
who have high rates of transmission you
have to treat this variant of concern as
a harder curve to bend down and
and the recent restrictions are bending
it down a little bit
but not enough because to avoid the
surge in cases it's like a new pandemic
it's like a new
kind of virus that's a lot like the
other virus it's it's
like it's child but it has more
transmissibility and that means
what we were doing before it was great
we're doing all the right things but
maybe we weren't doing them
strictly enough but bc's public health
officer is keen to stick to the original
plan
every person that's immunized protects
all of us
so we all need to focus on that right
now on getting
these hot spots taken care of because
that protects all of us as well
whistler did get shut down abruptly
ending the ski season
the hope is the vaccination drive will
help allow tourists back in its summer
season
it's an opportunity for us to turn our
minds towards summer and know that we'll
be able to really
provide a safe experience and that our
community will be protected
there are few travel options in this
pandemic whistler may be one of the few
destinations for canadians
if the virus can be contained robin gill
global news vancouver
doctors at toronto general hospital have
performed something historic
the first double lung transplant on a
covid19 patient in canada 61 year old
timothy sovay from mississauga was in
good health before he caught covet at
the end of last year
it ravaged his lungs so severely the
doctor who performed the surgery says a
transplant was the only option
his lungs had the same type of uh injury
and destruction as we see in many
of the patients that we treat in our icu
and the lungs even after having
significant
injury they can recover to a
you know normal or near normal function
so we only consider for transplantation
or patients that are fairly certain
that that lung won't get any better
and and and that's the way that or the
only way that that patient can be saved
the operation was in february and so
they is recovering well
the federal government is bailing out
air canada it has agreed to give the
airline 4 billion dollars in repayable
loans and
is taking a 500 million dollar equity
share in the airline
as a condition air canada has agreed to
pay refunds to canadians who had their
flights cancelled because of the
pandemic
that money will come from another 1.4
billion dollar loan
provided by the government the real
uh key criteria is
when you booked your flight
so you will have refunds available for
travel
that was purchased on or before
march 22nd of last year for travel
after february first of last year
that was cancelled either by the
passenger or by the airline
and then refunds will also be available
for flights purchased after march 22nd
of last year but where the airline
canceled the flight
those refunds are promised as soon as
possible beginning april 30th at the
latest
air canada has also agreed to keep a
minimum of 15 000 people employed
limit executive compensation and resume
service at 13 regional airports that had
been halted because of
low demand while the rest of us are
longing to go on vacation somewhere
almost 200 dutch people are
summing themselves at a five-star resort
in greece
and it's all backed by the government
playing some games drinking
cocktail and stuff the eight day greek
getaway is a test to see if safe
holidays are possible
the tourists are confined to the resort
where they are the only guests
they can use the pool restaurants and
other facilities but
not go to the beach very happy
been a long time since we've been on
holiday so
let's see if we can enjoy it even with
the restrictions we have
they need to take covet 19 tests during
their stay and after they get home where
they'll have to quarantine for 10 days
despite those restrictions about 25 000
people applied for this trip which is
costing each person about
600 dollars
a big day in england pub gardens
reopened for the first time in months no
indoor dining or drinking is allowed
though retail shops hair salons and
other non-essential businesses also
reopened today
the prime minister calls it a major step
forward on the road map to freedom
some restrictions are also being eased
in wales scotland and northern ireland
though
on different timelines the tight
restrictions and rapid vaccine rollout
has brought new covid19 case numbers in
the uk down to
22 per 1 million people across britain
48
of the population has now received at
least one vaccine dose
in canada it's about 19
prince harry is back in the uk for the
first time since that
oprah interview he will reunite with the
family at his grandfather's funeral on
saturday
in a statement today harry said the duke
of edinburgh was a man of service honor
and great humor
he was authentically himself with a
seriously sharp wit
harry says his grandpa was master of the
barbecue
legend of banter and cheeky right till
the end
right now he would say to all of us beer
in hand
oh do get on with it harry's wife megan
who is pregnant with their second child
is staying in california harry's brother
william also paid tribute to prince
philip today releasing this photo of him
with his great-grandson prince george
williams says his grandfather's century
of life was defined by service to his
country and commonwealth to his wife and
queen
and to our family he says he will never
take for granted the special memories
his children will always have
of their great grandpa coming to collect
them in his carriage
an investigation into military
misconduct
shut down coming up why one of the
hearings
is ending
the canadian military has been facing an
institutional crisis over allegations of
sexual misconduct among its highest
ranks
the house of commons defense committee
has heard hours of testimony trying to
determine who knew what
when now one of two parliamentary
investigations is being
shut down our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson
is following the developing details for
us
donna liberal mps backed by the block
quebecois have shut down hearings into
military sexual misconduct
by senior brass the vote means that key
political staff
from the minister of national defense's
office and the prime minister's office
will not be called to testify about
whether the prime minister
or his chief of staff were aware of
allegations against general vance in
2018.
conservative and ndp mps say hearings
are being cut off before
answers accountability or an apology
have happened
what we're trying to do is give
confidence to canadian women that they
can serve equally in the canadian
military
and that confidence comes only when they
know that these issues will be taken
seriously at the very highest level
we have not concluded this study and we
still have additional witnesses to hear
we still have no answer on why
a cds with outstanding
unresolved sexual allegations
allegations of sexual misconduct was
allowed to continue
in his position liberal mp anita
vandenbeld
says committee has to wrap up hearings
now in time to write a report with
recommendations
to be delivered to the government before
the summer recess
a prominent advocacy group for victims
of military sexual trauma
called it's just 700 say parties are
playing politics at committee
and they want to report an action as
soon as possible
however other victims are furious that
the hearings are ending now
donna mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks
fury in minnesota again another black
man is killed by police ahead we'll show
you the police body cam
footage
police in minnesota say an officer who
killed a black man in a minneapolis
suburb made a fatal mistake
twenty-year-old dante wright was shot
during a traffic stop it happened not
far from where george floyd was killed
and a warning this story does contain
disturbing images
police released body cam footage showing
the moments that led
to the fatal shooting they say the
officer intended to use a taser
but fired her gun instead as jackson
proskow reports the incident has
reignited tensions
in a community already on edge
he'd been pulled over for expired plates
and an air freshener on his mirror
and when police discovered an
outstanding warrant they tried to arrest
20-year-old dante wright
the officer's body camera video shows
wright appeared to try and get back
into the car
he drove a short distance before
crashing the vehicle and later died
it's my belief that the officer had the
intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr wright with a single
bullet an accidental discharge according
to the chief
wright's mother spoke to her son just
moments before that fatal encounter
that he was getting pulled over by the
police and i said well why
or did you get pulled over he said he
had they pulled him over because he had
air fresheners hanging from the rear
mirror
the officer involved is on
administrative leave that apparently
fatal mistake has led to calls for her
to be fired immediately
i do fully support releasing the officer
of her duties
in this suburb of minneapolis the death
of another black man
at the hands of police touched off a
night of protest and sporadic looting
police and the national guard responded
with tear gas and an overwhelming show
of force
at this time i am requesting again
sequestration of the jury
in view of the incidents of last night
not far away at the trial of former
minneapolis police officer derek chauvin
in the death of george floyd
the defense asked for the jury to be
sequestered fearing news about dante
wright could impact eventual
deliberations
i'm going to deny the motion to
sequester the jury and for additional
blood here
chauvin's fate could be in the hands of
that jury within a week
answers for the family of dante wright
could take much longer
police say there will be a full
investigation into whether this was
truly an accident
with the police chief in this
traumatized community
suggesting it's unlikely the officer
involved will ever return to duty
jackson prosko global news washington
next muslims in canada prepare for a
second ramadan
in the pandemic
there are plenty of things we miss these
days gathering together with family and
friends probably tops the list for most
people
celebrating and observing religious
traditions has been so difficult
muslims in canada will begin to mark the
holy month of ramadan tomorrow
limited by restrictions for a second
year in a row and as heather urex west
explains gathering after sunset
will be especially difficult in quebec
for patricia clifford and her family
ramadan is a special time of year
even if coveted restrictions are
limiting how they will be able to mark
the holy month
we have chances to go into the mosque
but against staggered
we do have to do appointments with it
and that that's okay we just you make do
you human beings we're adaptable
muslims spend their day fasting during
ramadan coming together at night to
share a meal
but in many parts of quebec the curfew
means no one can leave their homes
after 8 pm for us like basically ramadan
is
three main things number one is fasting
number two especially prayers
number three sharing the meals with the
ones who are lonely and who are hungry
and this year because of the curfew we
are losing almost
all three of them islam is a very social
religion
to help foster a sense of community
ahmadiyya muslim jamaat canada has
planned a series of virtual ramadan
events
so people can gather online every day
there will be
programs lectures sermons so that
you know they can at least feel
virtually as a community with
variants of concern driving exponential
growth of covet 19
medical experts are urging muslims to be
especially cautious
ramadan is not a one day event or a
weekend event
this is something that goes on and
continues for an entire month
it's why calgary's mayor plans to stay
safe
at home ramadan is a time for us to
remember community
and a time for us to remember charity
and how we look after one another
and so once again ramadan gatherings
will be quiet in clifford's house
as they look forward to a time when
everyone can come together
once more i keep saying inshallah which
means god willing
that this won't last for long heather
urex west global news
calgary and that is global national for
this monday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the bedford institute of
oceanography
in halifax please send us your canada to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and hope to see you
here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you